well we have a verdict in the um
defamation trial of infowars conspiracy
theorist alex jones and it is 49 million
dollars now how much of it can actually
be awarded per texas statutes is a
separate question how much of it can or
will be collected by the plaintiffs
is another question but this is the
verdict regardless let's take a look at
the moment that the judge read it out
remember that there were a four million
dollars in compensatory damages and then
we now get another 45 million in
punitive damages totaling nearly 40 uh
just over 49 million dollars
question number one
four million two hundred thousand
dollars
question number two
twenty million five hundred thousand
dollars
question number three
twenty million five hundred thousand
dollars
all right um
this question is addressed to my jury is
this your verdict so say
each and all of you
thank you very much uh would the
attorneys like to examine the verdict
so there it is ladies and gentlemen alex
jones 49.3
million dollar verdict as the los
angeles times accurately points out and
one of the things that michael cizak
from the associated press writes about
is what does this mean for the larger
misinformation ecosystem
a social media fueled world of election
denial coveted skepticism and other
dubious claims that alex jones helped to
build now there are many who are saying
this is a defeat for so-called free
speech
but as i know many of you are aware
there is not
um
how can we put this
i am aware
that even though i have my show
and i have my microphone and in a
literal sense i can say whatever i want
i can't just say anything and expect to
be free from the consequences of that if
i were to start targeting a private
citizen imagine that i had let's take
the eggman for example the our great
caller the eggman who has been calling
in and listening for over a decade
imagine that i started
giving out the eggman's real name and
saying things about him and and making
all of these claims specifically about
him he's just a private person who
sometimes calls in and doesn't even
identify himself by his real name and it
starts causing him problems at his job
and in his life and whatever i would not
expect that if he sues me for defamation
or doxing or whatever else
that i could just say it's free speech
and that's it it would be absurd for me
to think that that would be a valid
defense now maybe the things i say are
or aren't defamatory that's a very
specific question and part of it is
whether they are true
uh but there are limits to what i can do
with my platform i have a responsibility
on the platform not to do that and so
sure when i go after roger stone as
we're about to do a public person for
things he publicly says
that's one thing
but when you start saying
the victims of a mass shooting were
actors they they didn't really die the
parents are in on it here are specific
parents who are in on it that is not
free speech and it is not even with new
law under the existing infrastructure of
defamation law and other law you're not
allowed to do that so this is not about
free speech
and there is a question
as to whether
the
doctors and the bullies and all of them
uh who do this for a living
are now potentially going to be in
jeopardy because of the same legal
infrastructure nothing new no new law
has been created because of the same
legal infrastructure that may bring down
alex jones it's a real question we don't
yet know the answer as many of you know
i'm a busy person i don't always have
the exact correct nutritional plan for
my meals every single day and that's why
i also take a multivitamin and a couple
of supplements but doing them all
separately can be a little bit
time-consuming which is why athletic
greens is just fantastic and they're one
of our sponsors i've been using the
athletic greens since last year it just
really simplifies nutrition i just do a
scoop of the ag-1 and i'm getting 75
high quality vitamins and minerals and
my probiotics and it's all from whole
food sources i drink it in the morning i
know i'm good i don't have to be messing
around with different pills and
supplements or whatever or spend time
planning it when what time of day do i
need to take each one i just get it all
with one scoop you can put it in a
smoothie you can drink it straight it
tastes great and then i'm just good for
the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below